foreign
[Applause]
okay John music is your thing you are a
musician you play with the Beach Boys so
like you are so legit what am I doing
here Sammy Davis Jr taught you drums I
thought it'd be fun for you to teach me
drums John backstage during the
commercial was like do you know anything
you know how to play it and I was like
no so here we go so try play plate no
it's like two three four
that's good
[Music]
that's it
[Music]
[Applause]
thanks Rob
bass drum
keep going keep going keep going
now keep
[Music]
his face
wait you you really do know nothing
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
do that
[Applause]
I can't do anything
okay here
[Music]
[Music]
okay
[Applause]
you're so you're so good well I didn't
do much
would be proud I think he is french
fries I know he is okay
Todd Donna's a special surprise for me
oh my God I genuinely have no idea what
this is so I have no idea what's
happening come after the break and I
guess we'll all find out
[Music]
foreign
[Music]